the question I really wanted to ask is
is this the end of the Labour Party as
we know it
I think in some senses when Jeremy
Corbyn won that election as I said it a
sort of immediate aftermath of that it
the Labour Party had been transformed it
was a new party at that point so what
often happens actually in British
politics is that you have a party with
the same name but it's completely
different from what that party was ten
years before it's like the famous
problem of triggers broom no 10 new
handles four new heads but still the
same brain yeah
so in the same way if you think about
historically through a historic example
the Conservative Party by the end of the
1920s was a completely different kind of
party in terms of the people who are in
it the people who voted for it so what
it had been before the first world war
it had change basically from being an
hourish to critique party to being a
business party if you want to put it
that way so I think what happened with
with the Labour Party is that it was a
shell party under the Blair Blair and
brown the party's membership had shrunk
dramatically there was almost nothing
left and then all these thousands of
Corbin Easter's joined the party with
great enthusiasm and essentially it
became a new party now the question is
what kind of party is this and I think
the issue which is what we were rooting
to erm to go is is it going to continue
being a traditional working-class party
or will it become a party of the radical
populist left like say podemos in Spain
or maybe the Greens in Germany certifier
is hearing in Greece that kind of that
kind of thing I would have to say that
that's an open question because the the
other faction this is the trade unions
who are still of course enormously
powerful institutions and labour party
and obviously they represent the
traditional working-class aspect of it
however the leadership of the trade
unions has moved a long way away from
those organizations traditional
working-class roots so at the moment I'm
we all probably have a party called the
Labour Party around but I suspect it is
going to be less and less of a
working-class party
now in that case to go at the point you
raised earlier what kind of political
forces then
to be able to articulate working-class
interests and identity and concerns and
that could have a rather bad answer if
we're not careful so they Tommy Robinson
that it's a very rich scene for him to
plant if it if things don't work out yes
fortunately people like him are still
largely not taken serious or a
discredited because of their association
with thuggery and violence which not
surprisingly you know puts a lot of
people off the danger is that somebody
will arise who is charismatic persuasive
articulates the views and interests of
lost people very effectively but who
doesn't have the kind of baggage that
people like Tommy Robinson all the
football lads or whatever they call
themselves have the lads Alliance well
would you say the danger but if someone
came along for you you know people we
get a lot of [ __ ] actually for
criticizing tony robinson ourselves ya
know but you we but the issue with him
is I've listened to his Oxford Union
talk he explains a lot of things quite
articularly very well but it's that
association with violence and thuggery
say that for us is a problem a lot of
people want us to interview him and
we're like well he does say some things
that are interesting and there are valid
but that Association is a problem for us
right but what if someone was to come
along and articulate the views and the
needs and the interests of working-class
people up and down this country who was
not violent who wasn't coming from that
background what's wrong with that uh
actually I don't think there is anything
wrong with that I mean I think what he
said it was yeah I know everyone okay
I'm the practically rephrase present or
expanded slightly I think it is very
dangerous to have a significant bloc of
voters whose views concerns interests
are not being articulated that's very
dangerous and one of the problems I
think we've had in democratic politics
in most developed countries over the
last thirty years is the narrowing of
the range of concerns interests are
represented basically if you're a
university graduate and have a certain
set of views and you're working in
certain areas of the economy things are
pretty good your views are being
discussed but a lot of other people it's
not the case that's very dangerous
now the question is given that what form
does the politics that represents those
unrepresented currently underrepresented
interests take save you like in the past
working-class interests are not
represented at the end of the 19th
century so there were two different
roots that their representation talk one
was Tim for them to be represented by
radical but democratic parties like the
Labor Party
parties that you know were not prepared
to subvert civil liberties were
committed to preserving the main
institutions of the democratic political
process and the like the other roots in
say France for example was to go and
vote for the Communist Party a
Revolutionary Party that freaked Marley
was not interested in maintaining
democratic norms or liberal rights so
when we are talking about an
unrepresented working class or a working
class that feels itself to be
unrepresented which Maps the same thing
the question is then what kind of
politics comes along to express it if
it's a kind of politics which does
articulate their concerns and interests
but combines that with the kind of
radical revolutionary rhetoric or a
commitment to violence and the
destruction of their political opponents
that's extremely dangerous on the other
hand if it is the kind of politics which
says look here we have a set of views
and concerns that are not being taken
seriously we think they should be taken
seriously but does so within what you
might call the rules of the democratic
system that can't help but be a good
thing because it means that the people
who disagree with those of you who's all
that have queries about them will at
least have to take them seriously and
engage with them and this is the thing
what can I just now we've been talking
about this political figure maybe it's
me because I'm not oh because I'm not as
I favorite politics as everyone but
we're talking about this figure who has
led a movement that is a little bit
revolutionary addresses working-class
people's views it's Nigel Faraj isn't it
that's what I was about to some degree
yes absolutely the only problem that I
think Nigel frogs and he's of like the
element of you could be represented had
was that he was articulating Leah's
concerns but he also combined it with a
kind of economic position which
personally I favor
which was not going to I think appeal to
the audience he was also speaking for
because I think the crucial thing is
that you've got it on if you think of
there being a 4-way block four quadrants
really you've if the vertical axis up
here is this whole question of identity
that we're talking about the other axis
is how you feel about economic still and
so you've got on the one hand down here
a block of voters largely working-class
not entirely who are both left-wing and
economics and nationalists or culturally
traditionalist over here you have a
block of voters who share the cultural
traditional ISM but through a much more
free market or less left-of-center and
economics now up here on the other hand
you've got on the one hand the kind of
people that the independent group are
appealing to liberal Cosmopolitan's
broadly free market very globalist and
up here you've got the far left you've
got momentum and the greens now the
problem is that I think knives refer are
just down in this quadrant and his
economic view he's views on things like
national identity opposition to the EU
they appeal to those working-class folks
over here but his economic views did not
the big gap in the market if you will is
for a party that is left of center and
economics but traditionally nationalists
what I would call a national
collectivist party this is what the
front Nacional in France is that's what
marrying the pen is turned it into and I
think that that's the kind of big gap in
the market if you will it's like a
left-wing neither for us
[Music]